if you're looking for ways to develop
great habits outwork everyone and push
through failure then this video is for
you I could just out last other people
and I enjoyed being an instrument of
competition the people we see on
magazine covers that we might idolize
and feel we could never possibly emulate
because they have it all figured out
you have no insecurities they wake up
every morning and with a mental karate
chops they just master the day that's
not how it works over time you will make
mistakes you will have what people
perceive as failures but over time you
will win it's just it's almost an
inevitability need motivation watch a
top 10 with belief nation what's up it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world so let's
take your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew in today's lessons from a man who
went from working in sales for a data
storage company to becoming an
entrepreneur investor influencer and
writer of one of my favorite books of
all time the 4-hour workweek
he's Tim Ferriss and here's my take on
his top 10 rules to success volume 3
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
outwork everyone I think what I could
attribute my success is to is more the
fact that I was confident I could train
myself to absorb or tolerate very high
levels of pain to outwork other people
to win in sports like wrestling which is
all pain right and so I chose arenas in
which I felt like even if I lacked the
technical gifts even if I lacked certain
coaching advantages that I could still
win because I could just out last other
people and I enjoyed being an instrument
of competition how much and I still do I
mean I love competing I just like I'm
better in competition than I am in
rehearsal I understand yeah that's I
kind it's really weird but that's just
me I'd like I feed off doing what I love
love love love love about this is Tim
Ferriss is known as the 4-hour workweek
guy and everybody is trying to build
this passive income machine where they
don't have to do any work and here he is
the guy who builds the 4-hour workweek
saying that he works harder than
everybody else and that's how he wins
it's both it's working hard and working
smart stop trying to just work off of
four hours a week you win by working
hard I love it let's go to rule number
two learn before you earn find a
situation where you can be in the room
with masters of a craft and that could
just be deal making it could be joining
a small company say a fewer than 50
people where you simply get to observe
one of the principles negotiating in an
industry that you don't even care
anything about all right it could be
waste management and you want to go into
high tech but if you sit in a room with
someone who's an absolute pro at
crafting deals negotiating getting past
no those skills and maybe those
relationships start to snowball all
right and this is what scott adams the
creator and Dilbert would call
systems-thinking so instead of being
wedded to the outcome of a given job you
are accumulating skills and
relationships that transcend that job
okay and if you choose your environments
well because as I've said before and as
people like Drew the CEO of Dropbox as a
friend have said you're the average of
the five people you associate with most
all right so if you take just a few
years have the patience a few years to
really develop core competencies that
allow you to craft your own reality and
life negotiation deal-making getting
past though etc learning how to pitch
how to get someone's attention in 30
seconds so that you can then create the
desire and ultimately ask for some type
of action once you develop those then
you can really just create the map for
the next decade in the next several
decades so that would be it it would be
learned before you earn and it's never
too late to do that so I don't care if
you're coming out of college coming out
of high school
30 40 whatever it is Systems thinking
focus on the skills and relationships
first and then you can just create a
blank check for how much money you want
to make if that is your goal I love it I
agree I often say work for a company
that has 10 employees or less so you can
really get in the dirt of doing multiple
jobs and learn as much as you can and
I'd also say learn from videos learn
from people who you'll never have a
chance to go learn form in person
because they have great content in
videos in books the top ten rules that
meant to me series every time I watch
your video from somebody who I look up
to and respect I learn something and
makes me a better version of me let's go
to rule number three develop habits and
routines
whether it's jaco will link you
mentioned retired Navy SEAL commander
used to be in charge of all West Coast
training for the SEAL Teams which is
intense highly highly decorated where
there's Jocko saying discipline equals
freedom or you look at say some of the
writers or musicians or
rector's or others in the book across
pretty much all of them you find that
they find freedom in constraints so what
does that mean
sounds kind of weird it also sounds very
sounds like an oxymoron lit and what I
mean by that is all of these people have
routines they have set recipes that they
repeat on a daily and weekly basis so
that they are not making a lot of
extraneous decisions about mundane
things and I also recognize that we all
have our less ourselves our impulses I
love chocolate croissants for work if I
left my entire schedule to whim I would
just eat chocolate croissants all day
long I love them they're incredible and
I still do have them once a week I have
my cheat day and I'm allowed to do what
I want so I let my monkey mind and my
lesser self just go nuts
but these people all have typically
these and these are folks we might be
inclined to think of as superheroes and
maybe Jacko's a superhero but the vast
majority have one or two strengths they
may not even be the best of the world
but one or two strengths they combine in
a really unique way and they build
habits around those strengths and then
they have a thousand other weaknesses
but the habits and routines are what
help them from going off the rails and
this is really encouraging this should
be really encouraging because the people
we see on magazine covers that we might
idolize and feel we could never possibly
emulate because they have it all figured
out there you have no insecurities they
wake up every morning and with a mental
karate chops they just master the day
that's not how it works I know these
people almost everyone in this book
certainly on the podcast had become
friends with hundreds of these people
not true they have tons of not everyone
I don't speak for everyone but tons of
neuroses tons of terrible self-defeating
habits and the safety that they create
is habits and routines that's why jaakko
in part says discipline equals freedom
okay so you have trouble waking up in
the morning no problem you want to stage
this is something choco does takes his
clothing
prepares gets this sort of coffee ready
to brew clothing on the floor for the
workout right next to his bed prepared
the night before so there are no
decisions there are no opportunities to
make mistakes
between him openings eyes and Jocko
working out and you find this across
everybody I love this point and I'm
really taking a deep dive into learning
about habits and routines I agree I
don't wake up every day like yes believe
amazing it's my morning routine it's
it's this office right it's the
environments what I do every single day
every single morning that gets me set up
to have a great bold amazing day and
you've all had moments in your life that
you felt that boldness but it's just not
consistent and so understanding what the
triggers are for you what led you to
feel bold will let you to feel extremely
passionate and then planning that into
your morning routine so that you woke up
and then fell into that didn't have to
think about it it automatically happened
that you were going off and doing
something bold thinking bold do that for
a year your life will transform into
something unrecognizable from what it is
today
let's go to rule number four learn how
to make decisions another would be and I
don't know if you've ever had any
interaction with Kyle Maynard Kyle
maynard's fascinating guy he's he was
born a congenital quad amputee so he is
his arms and before the elbows and his
legs before the knees nonetheless he is
in the National Wrestling Hall of Fame
like collegiate wrestling and is the
first person to ever climb Mount
Kilimanjaro without prosthetics so he
military crawled the entire mountain
he's such a stud and he was taught by a
CEO at one point the CEO used this for
hiring but you can use it for anything
this particular CEO very successful
would have his current employees rank
prospective employees from one to ten
and that's not interesting by itself his
rule was you can't use seven so I wanted
a ranking from one to ten you can't
answer seven and what what ends up being
so beautiful about that and leveraged is
that seven is a safe number it's kind of
like the non offensive Switzerland of
answers it's not committal it's not too
bad so you can wiggle out of it whereas
if you're choosing a six that's barely
passing that's not good
if it's an eight you're indicating you
are pretty stoked like you're vouching
he forced them to make a decision
exactly so you can love it one to ten no
seven and so I've used that and kylus
used it for say write anything in
patient to conferences invitations to
coffee whatever it might be it's like
decisions in life decisions in life I
really love this clip and I've used this
myself and also help other entrepreneurs
with it the idea of not using a seven
you have to eliminate seven and you have
to pick an eight or six I love it I love
that concept is such a great strategy to
use I hope you guys apply to your
business because gonna make a huge
difference Tom's rule number five
overcome your fears what you have been
doing hasn't been working so you have to
try to say all right well what is
something new a new way I can approach
it there's a lot of the parties that
involve alcohol
what if there's parties advocated around
fitness and health and smoothies and
juicing Pat you know and so you're
excited about it and you're like you're
convincing me I'm like yo I want to get
my green smoothie on what happened like
oh how do i how do I do that I mean what
was the worst thing that could have
happened if you actually went for it I
guess the worst thing will be just no
one shows up as I thought it might be
interesting to have it right now try a
coffee challenge a way the coffee
challenge is where you go up to some
random person the guy in there they
don't know about it and you ask for ten
percent off she's very timid she can be
extremely timid and shy why would I ask
for a discount coffee we have to train
her to get to the point where she can
walk through those irrational fears and
you start with silly things via people
ask for discounts on your classes
[Music]
if I could do that means she should do
it yeah it's all yours I'm kind of
nervous yeah like me nervous
yeah knock em dead you'll do great all
right
fear is a really interesting animal it's
something that we all face in different
ways but I get one mate' the 10% off on
there you have to inoculate yourself
against the fear of rejection
uncomfortable conversations asking for
things you think you might not deserve
but really need so it's like yeah sure
what's the special occasion okay
congratulations yeah thank you you can
really train for the big stuff that
you're afraid of by practicing with the
really little things
man that was another great clip Tim is
is bringing it on this one all the great
things in your life come on the other
side of your fear it's your fear that
are holding you back from achieving
great things I love this clip watch it
again ingrain it in your system it's
super important thank you Tim for the
reminder let's go to number 6 love
yourself I realized I take two years ago
but especially in the last six months
very recent that and this is the part
that would make my Tim of five years ago
just crane like vomit a little in his
own mouth much of this I'm not gonna
mince words I still have trouble sayings
like self-love is not an indulgence it's
not a nice to have it is a prerequisite
even if all you want to do is feel
successful and take care of the people
you love the most to really take care of
them you have to as I've heard said put
on your oxygen mask first and if you
don't do that
like you you are also shortchanging your
ability to care for other people
completely and that that's been a very
very much an hundred and eighty degree
about-face for me
right because for a long time I was like
I don't need to care for myself mmm like
that's the word keeps going back to me
which is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent mink
who cares so this is a great clip I
think the message itself is fantastic
you hear it over and over and over again
on these top tens you have to love
yourself but I love especially the one
84 Tim I love the recognition of his own
growth in his own evolution and
questioning some of his other beliefs
that he used to have that he's outgrown
and don't serve Him and finding new ones
I do I think that's super important and
in watching these videos if you find
something that you keep hearing over and
over and over again and you don't agree
with it but you keep hearing it like you
may want to just question yourself a
little bit because all these super
successful people are saying the same
thing maybe there's something to it
maybe you just need to take a little bit
of time and reflect on it because it
might actually make your life better I
love that part of this clip let's get to
rule number seven find the right mentors
very frequently we'll ask someone for
instance what advice would you give to a
30 year old just getting started here in
your industry what is the best advice
you would give and just as important I
think you should ask what advice should
that person ignore or what is the worst
advice that you hear repeated often in
your industry what is the conventional
wisdom that you disagree with those type
of questions give you a not to do list
and it is what you don't do that
provides the space for what you can do
anyone who says you should do this the
way I did it without any caveats should
be maybe ignored
in many cases but certainly viewed with
suspicion the the type of mentors who
tend to be the most helpful or those who
don't necessarily give you an answer but
they give you a better way of finding
that answer I'm leaving my second job I
want to start my own company what should
I do and they say well I can't tell you
what you should do because I don't have
enough information
which is a huge credibility point in my
mind that they have the awareness to say
that and they said but if I were in your
position here's how I might think
through it so look for mentors who don't
necessarily give you answers but who
walk you through the process of how they
might think about making the proper
decision given all of your particulars
and I think that's what
in my experience separates a mediocre or
decent mentor from a great mentor so I
know what name does clip find the right
mentors but in watching it I really
resonate with the mentor side not the
mentee side I try to apply that
philosophy to the people on my team to
my son to the people my family who might
have to mentor and not just saying
here's how it has to be done because
that's how I would do it but helping
them think through a better answer I
think that's really hard it's really
hard especially when you know that
you've had it made and you know how to
do it yourself to not force people to
have to do it the same way you did it
but allow them to uncover themselves and
find the right path for them I think
that's the toughest part of being a
mentor and I'm really glad things write
it up in this clip alright time for
number eight push through failures I
like the idea of showing people both the
successes and the failures so they can
see net-net that it's actually low risk
if that makes sense I guess like a mess
like that if you're if you're developing
skills and relationships and that's how
you choose your projects and you're not
trying to appeal to the entire world
you're trying to find your 1,000 true
fans who are just as crazy about cricket
protein or whatever it might be as you
are over time you will make mistakes you
will have what people perceive as
failures but over time you will win it's
just it's almost an inevitability and so
if I can showcase that for people or
they're like oh I saw Tim Ferriss
publicly faceplant when he did I a B and
C and television that didn't work out I
saw him tried this new thing with this
one book that didn't work out but still
like in between II had this huge success
and this huge success this is a
consistent message again for successful
people that you fail and you fail and
you fail and you fail and you fail your
way to success that's how you end up
winning what I love specifically about
this video though is Tim putting the
failures on a pedestal and showing it
off and say look here's my failure I'm
out of my failure instead of just trying
to hide it to make it easier and to give
permission to everybody else watching to
say it's okay if I fail to so I really
respect that about Tim and a huge fan of
this clip let's go to rule number nine
define things clearly I did it at my
risk you know this is an important
question because I realized that a lot
of the knots we tie ourselves into and
the a lot of the anxiety that we feel is
actually due to using words that are not
defined very well like success I just
want to be successful well you better
have a very clear definition on what
that is if it's going to be one of your
mind and your main obsessions young lady
or young man yeah
happiness yeah that's a slippery one too
and risk is another one risk to me is
the likelihood of an irreversible
negative outcome yes that's it that's it
so define that way they're actually very
few serious risks and I choose to take
very few serious risks people might view
me as a risk taker I don't think myself
that way at all I really love the
perspective Tim is bringing really in
all of these clips I think if I look at
this series of top ten rules of success
it's why I profile so many different
people from so many different walks of
life because success - Tim is different
than success - the Dalai Lama and is
different than success - Elon Musk and
somebody else and my goal is to show you
a bunch of different perspectives not so
that you can just copy them but so that
you can define what success looks like -
you take the best parts for you and
apply it to your life let's go - rule
number 10 last rule before the bonuses
meditate I get a lot of questions about
how to start meditating keeping in mind
that I had a very severe allergy to the
word and concept of meditation for a
very long time more than a decade and
I've only really consistently started
meditating and implemented meditating
for the last two to three years now this
is why I think meditation
be viewed in a way as stoic training or
in some ways similar to CBT cognitive
behavioral therapy because the objective
is to help you to observe your state and
your thoughts so that you are less
controlled by them what does this mean
I'll use an analogy that I think was
originally shared with me by Andy pretty
comb who is the founder of something
called headspace which I'll talk about
in a second which is the difference in
effect being say standing out in the
storm getting pelted with rain and hail
and wind and stinging your eyes and so
on being soaking wet or standing inside
looking through the glass at the storm
the latter is meditation the way I've
put it before which is slightly
different it's the difference between
being in the washing machine or standing
outside looking into the washing machine
and when you have that somewhat detached
observer perspective you can just be
much calmer much more appreciative and
ultimately effective I do not think that
meditation causes you to lose your edge
this was a concern of mine and I think
it's a concern of a lot of type-a driven
people but even if it did cause you to
lose saying 10% who cares ultimately
you're trying to succeed and make more
money do all these things build a bigger
business to improve the quality of life
for yourself or others and you achieve
that I think more directly in many cases
by even if you had to take say a 10%
haircut on your edge by improving your
present state awareness and by much much
more fifty two hundred percent so let's
jump into a couple of options right so
if you're not a dog because dogs are
always present then you need some human
tools one option and this is the way I
started very early on meditating was
listening to one song so find one song
that puts you into a good mood and in
the morning all you're gonna do is sit
comfortably so this could be sitting in
a chair feet on the floor just like this
hands in your lap you generally are
gonna want some type of back support you
do not need a dog chewing on a squeaky
toy so I may intervene
Molly come here I'll grab that freak out
or you can sit like this which is how I
tend to sit when I meditate so this is
not full Lotus this is half Lotus it's
not even half Lotus it's really just one
foot tucked into the crease of my calf
and thigh and then I'm going to kind of
pull the butt cheeks so that I have a
nice little seat here back flat and then
my hands are how they're gonna be in my
lap like so or I will actually post my
hands on my thighs like this which can
also help if you have a tendency of
slouching to keep your back straight all
right
listen one song for me it was we're
gonna party like it's 1999 Prince it's
hard to be stressed out worrying about
things if you listen that song trust me
you can pick whatever poison you like
but this was shared with me by Kamal
raava Khan and he suggested listen to
one song doing nothing in particular
other than listening to the song and
breathing and that's three to four
minutes that's it so you could try that
in the morning so meditation has been a
source of stress for me I believe
meditation works I've never felt the
benefit of it I think in general I'm not
highly emotional in terms of making
decisions and I don't get caught up in
the storm that often so maybe that's not
then maybe that's why I'm not a huge
practitioner or maybe it's just an
excuse so I'm telling myself I don't
believe that it takes off your edge and
I believe the science where you see you
know people's brain activity and I
believe that it can make a big
difference and I've I've tried multiple
versions to try to get it to work and
including headspace and haven't found
the thing I'm encouraged by the fact
that Tim went from absolutely hating it
to being a regular practitioner I am
looking for the right resource to help
me finally be able to feel the benefits
I'll look into more what Tim is doing if
you guys have suggestions I would love
to know it because that's one of those
things that keeps coming up over and
over and over again highly successful
people are very often meditating and I
can't get it working for
me so I'd love I love some help believe
nation so that's my take on Tim Ferriss
his top ten rules to success vol 3 my
favorite rule that's a tough one so many
great ones on here I would probably go
with number one though rule number one
outwork everyone not because it was
super insightful to me more because of
how many people looked at him and see
hey I just want to work four hours a
week and they miss they missed the fact
that the guy is hustling his face off
like he is working extremely hard to get
his goals accomplished and it's not just
about living a 4-hour week you can't you
can't accomplish big things in your life
and have a huge impact that you can have
if you're only working four hours a week
so that's my favorite rule I'd love to
know from you guys is rule number one
your favorite or is there one that is
better for you leaving the comments
below I'm really curious to see what you
have to say
now I made this video because Chris
seven eight to zero
asked me to if there's somebody like me
to profile and a future top ten video
check out the link in the description
you can go cast your vote on the request
line and maybe will pick your choice
finally I want to give a quick shout-out
to joe cosgrove jr. joe thank you so
much man for picking up a copy of my new
book the top ten rose a success and
posting it to your LinkedIn account with
the pretty bow on it - I love it
Thank You Man for the support and I hope
you enjoyed the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is let's
love I'll see you soon
I've spent a lot of my life really angry
and using rage and anger a lot of it
directed at myself as a fuel for
becoming a competitor because the only
wealth the only way that I felt
validated or valuable was to win period
that's it I was an instrument for
winning and competing and I only felt
good in in relationship to other people
by somehow being able to tolerate more
pain work harder to be number one and it
was more a relief of not feeling
terrible about myself for a fraction of
a day then it was the joy of winning if
that makes sense it totally and so for
my whole life I've been so completely
brutal to myself and I've realized
through a number of different means you
know one of which anybody can pick up
which is actually a book called radical
acceptance by Tara brach which terrible
terrible title love Tara brach but very
very helpful introduction to thinking
about the potential idea that if you
want to really help people or you want
to really love people you can't do it if
you have if you hate yourself you just
cannot fully do it you cannot I don't
think it's possible so the last few
years have been and especially the last
one or two years a process of asking
different questions and one of the
questions there are many different
questions but one of the most important
which which is right up front in this
book and the reason the book kind of
exists in a way is what what might this
look like if it were easy things are
hard enough or they can be and there's
so much uncertainty in the world that
for type-a personalities or people
who've been wounded and have become very
highly competitive as a result are
highly driven I'm hardly driven yeah
right and
Riven we usually use as a very
complementary descriptor but you know
horse that's being whipped to run faster
until it dies on the track is also being
driven yes and that's not always a good
thing and very often a bad thing
that question what might this look like
if it were easy is a really deceptively
leveraged question because you start to
look for elegance and ease instead of
the path of complexity that allows you
to absorb and tolerate the most pain
which some people myself included for a
long time
viewed as an indicator of doing the
right thing or and sometimes for me of
strength yeah yeah it's like oh yeah no
I can read line for longer than all of
you
yep it's like wait a second yeah wait
what do we talk yes
and this is good yeah this thing like
and there don't get me wrong there there
is strength and there are advantages to
having endurance but only when you're
enduring things that are worth enduring
mm-hmm as opposed to just making your
life painful so long answer long
monologue but I do think it's very
important to talk about the darkness and
the failures and the hard times and when
I interview people I always try to bring
that out because it's so easy like you
said to listen to an interview or to see
someone on the cover of a magazine and
think to yourself wow I really wish I
could do something like that but I'm me
and they're them and they've got to
figure it out
yeah and they always wake up at 6:00 in
the morning with like a mental karate
chop to conquer the day with no
insecurities and that's just [ __ ]
it's not true and I can tell you with
first-hand knowledge knowing some of the
most impressive people I've ever come
across in the world who've become my
friends we all have our demons so I want
I make a real conscious effort to talk
about those so that people can try to
create a safety net against
self-destruction and certainly at least
self-flagellation
and berating raise your standard Apple
at the core its core value is that
people passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe it's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details